la longue marche vers une douloureuse
guérison peut commencer
la fin du processus judiciaire pour un
des pires tueurs en série du pays
le juge john bateman a rappelé que bruce
mais carter comme huit meurtres
prémédités entre 2010 et 2017 qu'il
avait ciblé les hommes pour leur
vulnérabilité
soit parce qu'ils avaient des liens avec
la communauté lgbt ou qu'ils étaient
migrants le jeu j'ai ajouté que blues
mais carter avait des membres et ses
victimes et cacher les restes humains
pour son propre plaisir tordu le juge
unique mandat condamné donc le meurtrier
à la prison à vie sans possibilité de
libération conditionnelle avant 25 ans
l'osm et qu'arthur est demeuré
impassible fixant ses souliers pour
expliquer sa décision le juge a rappelé
que l'assassin a plaidé coupable qu'il a
67 ans et que ses chances d'obtenir une
libération conditionnelle sont minimes
au mieux ce n'est pas assez rassurant
pour les familles répond cet ami dan
zhang bin une des victimes
nous sommes trop clément au canada
ajoute t-elle les proches d'une autre
victime sont venues du sri lanka pour
assister aux procédures strictes et ils
s'attendaient à 50 ans sans possibilité
de libération conditionnelle
comme la couronne réclamait à glacer
prix car soyons honnêtes rétorque chef
de police de toronto
je ne crois pas que vous semez carter va
revoir la lumière du jour
la communauté lgbt a vécu pendant des
années dans la peur de la présence d'un
tueur en série et la méfiance envers les
policiers qui ne protégeait pas nous
devons maintenant réapprendre à nous
sentir en sécurité et à faire confiance
aux autres 17 révérende promet de
rebâtir les liens une tâche qui
s'annonce ardue les policiers ont nié
longtemps la présence d'un tueur en
série à toronto et on sait maintenant
qu'ils ont interviewé blues mais carter
à deux reprises en 2013 et en 2016 sans
l'accuser de quoi que ce soit ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto